some people are hard-wired to love the
ocean spending days swimming and surfing
and sailing but for this marine
biologist
that's not immersive enough she prefers
to be far below the surface exploring
the seas in experimental submarines
my favorite thing is being underwater
I've spent a whole year of my life
underwater now in hours 9,000 hours
underwater for me it's pure magic and I
feel like I could just live there
forever
hands down I'm completely obsessed it's
all I want to do with my life my name is
shanece top Netsky and I am a submarine
mother and pilot in 2018 she left her
PhD program in marine biology so she
could share her passion for underwater
exploration with others she raised money
to buy two submarines not toluca and a
homemade sub called fangtooth yes an
actual yellow submarine we bought
Frankie for $4,000 you can just buy from
submarine for $4,000 both are named
after Sea Life bang tooth is this
monstrous deep-sea fish and not to Lucas
in talons is a bioluminescent
dinoflagellate responsible for this sea
Sparkle each submarine has its own
character and its own things that it can
do and so we want to have sort of one of
each style so that people can work on
the ones that resonate the most with
them yeah I mean I think that we need to
replace all the pneumatic valves but
both subs needed a lot of work work that
Ginni and her team took on themselves my
credentials are none the thing with
these types of projects is that they are
as serious as people take them it's a
combination of boating and various art
and engineering projects that I've
engaged in over the last five years that
have given me confidence to be able to
approach a project like this but I am in
a state of learning for sure
right now this project is a hobby and
not a job I hope to one day be able to
get paid because it's a lot of hours
normally I work as a marine scientist
and I do this as a hobby but they're all
are bent weird that was a big leak we're
trying to get the subs perfectly
operational so that we can use them to
train people and to give people the
experience of a of being able to dive at
all and be of empowering people to do
the operations of themselves fangtooth
SHINee's first experimental sub it's
homemade built by a man in his garage
with parts he got at the hardware store
he sold it and it eventually ended up in
the hands of SHINee and her team they've
taken it out on about 50 dives but it's
still a work in progress
thank you three dive to about 30 feet
max and that's because of the way that
her friend viewport isn't don't you know
the pressure from the outside sort of
will bend the acrylic over that piece it
was it not super well thought-out design
so she's limited to just just 30 feet so
thank you this is like our accessible
little toy submarine it's just a really
simple system there's just a few levers
you add water you add compressed air
that's it Fang tooths mechanics are
pretty easy to use it has four ballast
tanks filled with air two in the front
one in the center and one in the back
these keep the sub afloat on the surface
but when SHINee releases air from the
ballast tanks and floods them with water
it weighs down fangtooth and lets it
sink as soon as i'm under the water I go
from being a little bit nervous to
having just this total profound calmness
and contentedness so as soon as we're
submerged as soon as you know the
hatches underwater I transition from
feeling you know anxious about what's
going on and worrying about all the
controls to just feeling this extreme
sense of peace when she's ready to
surface she slowly refills the ballast
tanks with air that she brew
down with her making fangtooth buoyant
again
she's also just really cute and fun
people that normally would be really
intimidated by all of the mechanics just
to have just to see this thing and have
it feel like more psychologically
accessible because of its playfulness
fangtooth is not yellow anymore because
we never want to hear the Beatles song
again and so thanks he's got painted
white as the base coat for her new paint
job where she's gonna get painted by a
street artist and will be a much more
accessible little creature than she was
before with her Captain America shield
fangtooth is considered an experimental
class submarine there are commercially
available submarines but they come with
a price tag of a few million dollars
largely because of the costly
certification process but with fangtooth
and other experimental class subs di
wires like shinee skip over these steps
so in the United States I would estimate
that there may be 30 experimental class
subs it's hard to gauge because a lot of
people will do it without telling other
people but of the active community that
is around sort of DIY subs I would say
they're about they're probably 30 in
various states of repair and desert
they're in the US but you can't just buy
them usually you have to sort of
demonstrate your competence so that you
know whoever built the sub originally
doesn't want to have to worry that
something terrible is gonna happen so
you kind of need to be a part of the
community before it's even an option
it's not usually an option to just show
up and buy one I was very persuasive
they're actually way safer than people
think they are but of course you could
die I mean you're in a steel capsule in
the depths like you could conceivably
die but it's actually way safer than
people have in their minds and it's just
because there's so much mitigation for
everything that could possibly go wrong
we are going to have a max bottom time
of 15 minutes after 20 minutes please
initiate
yeah nakta Lucca is SHINee in her
group's second submarine originally it
was commissioned by the Swedish army and
then it passed through the hands of the
anti-whaling activist group the sea
Shepherd Conservation Society and then
it ended up here with some amateur
submarine enthusiasts dr. Luka currently
has a couple air leaks in the pneumatic
system and the high-pressure air system
we have a high minor hydraulic league
it's just little things that pop up all
the time a couple gauges are down and so
we're just trying to replace every
single little components and make sure
that she's really ready to go the sea
trials is just a lot of testing of what
to expect when you're out in the field
and then to be able to prepare
accordingly dr. Luka was tested to a
crush depth of 1,200 feet which means at
this given the safety factor in the time
that she was built that's a rated depth
of 300 feet we're hoping to do some
retrofitting to enable her to go deeper
but she has a ding in her front viewport
we need to replace the viewport before
we can go to her full rated depth and
then we hope to get a beefier viewport
that'll allow us to go deeper and then
there's just a few more mods that we
would have to make to it not allow her
to go much deeper we are preparing to
ascend
turns out shinee and her crew aren't the
only ones interested in exploring the
oceans with fangtooth so Fang tooth was
stolen it was very hectic for a few
hours as I called every single law
enforcement person and asked them if
they had actually yes for reals seeing a
yellow submarine I wasn't joking we're
like no are you kidding like that's not
funny
like no no I'm serious yellow submarine
someone can be dying in there right now
it's actually kind of important and so I
was really frantic because I was scared
someone was gonna get hurt so it's super
easy to get yourself into trouble if you
don't know how to rescue it yourself out
of these things and so I was very
relieved to hear that she had been
retrieved by the ever evil police SHINee
continues to work on Fang tooth and
knock DeLuca bringing them both closer
to her vision and she actually wants to
buy more submarines but for her it's not
just about teaching the public how to
work on and pilot these underwater
vessels when you go in a sub dive there
are all of these gelatinous creatures
that have absolutely nothing in common
with anything you've ever seen before
they're absolutely magical and they just
have all of these behaviors and textures
and colors that have nothing no
relationship to any land creatures and
it's utterly captivating to see these
things that are truly there aliens on
our own planet
[Music]